increasing numbers of covet cases in
China have put India on alert the
government has now approved the use of
nasal vaccines as a booster shot it is
said to be available from Friday Court
developed by Indian company Bharat
biotech it will initially only be
available in private hospitals meaning
people will have to pay for it
but India is also implementing other
measures here's India's Health Minister
addressing Parliament on Thursday
with the emergence of changing variants
of covid-19 the government is taking
suitable steps to face the challenges
the states have been advised to step up
surveillance and they are being advised
to take appropriate steps to control the
spread
the states have also been advised to
increase the genome sequencing of
positive cases
so that in case there is a new variant
it is identified
and suitable steps are taken to control
its spread foreign
that's not all people have been advised
to mask up and maintain social
distancing also the government says it
could make a negative covet test report
mandatory for international passengers
arriving from countries with a high
caseload already it has started random
testing of international arrivals at
airports the plan is to test two percent
of incoming passengers
for more I'm joined from Delhi by DW
correspondent Manila Chaudhary Manila
the government appears to be on point a
number of Quick decisions in the past
few days
both the government and the people are
concerned when it comes to the news of
spread of Rapid infection coming from
China both the Prime Minister and the
health Minister have been conducting
several meetings to assess the cover
situation in the country the Prime
Minister has asked officials to ramp up
surveillance measures the health
Minister has told the Parliament that
they will be conducting random testing
of people International Travelers at the
end at the at several international
airports to see if there's any infection
or any variant coming in so decisions
are definitely being taken
how prepared other countries
Laboratories to quickly sequence genomes
and for the health system to respond to
any new potential outbreak
s the second we have several decisions
were taken to improve the healthcare
infrastructure of the country because
there were allegations of the government
not doing enough or not doing anything
so several decisions were taken at that
time including the decisions regarding
the Laboratories so earlier this year
six private Laboratories were given
approval to conduct you know sequencing
and that has been they haven't given the
approval so definitely we do have more
apologies to do that both the Prime
Minister and the health Minister have
been asking the states and other
officials to ramp up their capacity of
genome sequencing but a lot of experts
in news reports are saying that India
has ample capacity to do that
you said earlier that people are
concerned and you also reported quite a
bit through India's very deadly second
wave last year when hundreds of
thousands of people died is this a
trauma that is seared into people's
minds
definitely trauma was there and perhaps
the memory of that is the reason that
people are concerned many people I spoke
to are concerned about the news coming
in from China about the infection
spreading there but having said that
India uplifted it I'm sorry India listed
its covert we took his long back the
live normal lives have resumed people
are not wearing masks people are not
made any social distances even uh the
awareness campaigns by the government
has lost it in Spain so a lot now
depends on how well the government can
restart this awareness campaigns of the
importance of wearing masks or
maintaining hygiene looking at the
rising number of cases
Manila will leave it there thanks so
much for joining us manure chaudry from
Delhi
now let's get the scientific view on
this from Gotham men and he's a
professor of biology at Ashoka
University in Northern India and works
in disease modeling as well Professor
Menon you've monitored India's covet
outbreaks since the beginning should
India be worried about the increasing
cases we are seeing in China
it should be wedded for one reason and
not worried for another it should be
worried because any rise in cases
anywhere in the world is important
because it's just more opportunities for
the virus to change to mutate into a
more transmissible form it should be
less worried because already India has
been through three waves of the pandemic
including an obikron wave earlier in
this year in which many people have
already been infected probably the bulk
of our population much of our population
is vaccinated and boosted so overall I
would think that the risks of something
runaway happening in India are really
relatively low
okay let's pick about some of some of
those points one by one beginning with
the Omicron variant rather the Omicron
subvariant bf7 which is apparently
driving the surge in China now this was
sequenced in India back in July itself
is it a very deadly sub-variant
it doesn't seem to be very different
from the regular Omicron variant
remember that China has not seen any
level of cases and infections that India
did for example already the Indian
population is very well protected
through a combination of an Omicron
infection earlier in the year even up to
the middle of the year as well as
vaccinations so we most Indians at this
time have some level of hybrid immunity
towards the disease which the Chinese
lack completely so what could happen in
China could be very different are
histories in terms of the disease are
very different
you talked about the the vaccinations I
think the figure is about more than 90
percent of the population has at least
received two shots but there's only
about 27 percent of India's population
that has received a third booster shot
you do not think that that is a cause of
concern
that is indeed a cause of concern so one
thing that the government should do is
to increase booster availability and in
fact we'll still uptick in the over 60
population because it's known that the
elderly are often most in danger of an
adverse consequence of a covid-19
infection that they should do they
should also explore the new protein
subunit vaccine that are now available
to see if they might be alternative
booster that might provide better
protection so certainly increasing
booster coverage should be a priority of
the government but otherwise I don't
think we should unnecessarily Panic at
this stage
after those two shots were given uh
initially there was take up of the
booster shot but then it sort of petered
away once it became clear as you said
Indians have some sort of an immunity
having gone through so many waves of the
virus and people sort of slackened off
if I can say trying to get that booster
shot do you think that that hesitancy if
I can call it that that hesitancy is
going to change now that the population
sees what's happening in China and in
other places
I think it will change but I think the
messaging around that should be more
positive rather than negative saying
here's an additional means of protection
not that this is going to take over our
world is going to be back to the to to
the early parts of 2021 when we
underwent the undevastating Delta wave I
don't think the situation is as dire as
that because as you said there have been
multiple rounds of Omicron infection
most people have had two vaccine doses
but it is I think very sensible for the
government at this point to press for
uptake for an increased uptake of the
booster dose the government has also
asked people to mask up and maintain
social distancing this didn't really
work previously and we have Festival
season we are in fact in Festival season
right now any reason to believe these
instructions directives requests will
work this time round
that's a very good question I think
people are fairly exhausted after about
two years of of listening to the
government carefully on instructions
about masking a long period of lockdown
Etc so I think
the sensible people will be sensible and
they will recognize that this is a time
to be cautious with increase in cases
this is also a time when the rest when
the flu season takes over across much of
India so from multiple points of view
not just covid-19 it does make sense to
avoid crowded spaces to mask up Etc I
would prefer that enforcement is
non-punitive rather than punitive
regarding this what we need is more
public awareness in many ways as
possible regarding the sense of actually
masking when you're in a public place
avoiding public spaces in general
avoiding large crowds especially at this
time
now we talked last year when India had
faced its deadly second wave of
infections that driven of course by the
Delta variant India was completely
overwhelmed medical facilities
overwhelmed and swamped is India better
prepared now
we're best prepared in some ways I think
oxygen availability will no longer be a
concern at the moment and we do have you
know some experience now in dealing with
a rapidly spreading infectious disease
like covert native respiratory disease
like over 19. but I don't really think
at the moment there's nothing really
that that leads us to believe that
people have anything like the Delta wave
as a consequence of the Chinese
infections I think we are substantially
protected now the situation is not the
same as it was a year ago or so this
situation has changed for the better in
a sense and that we are substantially
protected against adverse consequences
of another variant hopefully it will not
be very very different from what we are
saying so far right sorry to interrupt
you there I wonder if I can ask you a
specific question about genome
sequencing because this is what the
government wants the government wants
early genome sequencing and it's asked
the states of India to ensure that this
happens where is India with genome
sequencing now our facilities there is
could any variant dangerous subvariant
be detected in time
I think it could be but I think that the
issue there is more correlating the
variant with the disease and what you
should watch out for is
symptoms is sort of more serious
versions of the disease and then try to
correlate that with the variant that
might be causing it that's really the
concern it doesn't really matter if you
have a mild infection that you don't
detect matters much less what matters is
is it likely to send you to hospital to
an ICU to make you require oxygen and so
on that's where the connection between
looking at the patient's clinical
aspects with the sequence of the of the
virus that's infecting them is important
we are roughly at the level of
sequencing where we should be able to
make this connection what we need is
more transparency more availability of
the data on a real-time basis so that
there are no delays in making these
connections I do want to talk to you
about what you think about the
government's performance here because in
the past 48 Hours we've seen a number of
high-level meetings we've had the health
Minister taking meetings we've had the
Prime Minister taking meetings do you
think looking at all of this that the
government has learned from its
performance during past waves of the
virus when it was heavily criticized for
inaction or ill-timed action and that
the government is acting better now
I think it certainly has made a
difference and I do like to I in fact I
I'm pleasantly surprised to see this
level of concern and attention being
given there's a lot of it is also media
hype around this so I think the intense
attention of the media on China and
potential consequences of India is also
leading in some sense to this government
response I'm very happy to know that
they have been measured in what they
have done they have not shut down
flights which as we know doesn't really
make much of a difference they've been
sensible they've not ordered large-scale
lockdowns or anything they have been
measured in what they are contemplating
I think this is the right way to proceed
I'm I'm very appreciative of the fact
that they're considering this carefully
they're meeting at regular intervals so
that they can update and and and act in
a quick manner should it be required at
any later point